[Music]
stranger things 4 volume 1 ends with a
massive cluster of cliffhangers fechna's
identity is revealed but he still hasn't
unveiled the extent of his master plan
and he's also far from the only threat
out there fortunately answers are just
around the corner and the super-sized
final episodes of stranger things four
he's not going to stop
not until he's taken everyone
after keeping a demogorgon at bay with
nothing but a lit torch and sheer
intimidation jim hopper has had a
weapons upgrade and he looks like he's
handling it just fine cutting through at
the 1 30 mark of the trailer the heroic
hopper stands tall wielding what looks
to be a sword cool enough to make conan
the barbarian jealous
his specific location isn't that clear
but chances are he's still in russia
searching for a way home in the grand
scheme of things it's an interesting
weapon of choice for the former lawman
especially considering the fact that
everyone else in the trailer is tooling
up with shotguns and flamethrowers go
nuts murray hopper himself also wields a
gun elsewhere in the trailer this
suggests to us that hopper is likely
facing off against some human opposition
in this shot rather than the upside
down's heartier stock
with that said in a show that's made
dungeons and dragons an unofficial guide
to battling supernatural forces it makes
sense that someone is finally going to
get a sword to do some damage who better
than 11's fatherly knight in shining
armor
volume 2 of stranger things 4 will
undoubtedly lead 11 to go for a rematch
against henry creel aka the horrifying
slasher villain vechna the only question
is whose turf will it take place on we
can't say for sure but the trailer
offers tantalizing hints that 11 will be
returning home both in the right side up
and the upside down
judging by the latest teaser we see 11
out in the open air away from the test
facility she was confined to in volume
1. we also get a final glimpse of l
returning to where it all began the
creel home has she come to save max
lucas and erica who looked to have
headed there as well or is this the
final showdown that will close the door
on vecna for good
just in case jim hopper and company
aren't having a miserable enough time
with just one demogorgon volume 2 of
season 4 sets them up against more than
one invader from the upside down toward
the end of the trailer viewers are
treated to a brief shot of a demidog
tearing through the corridors of the
russian prison apparently chasing hopper
familiar from the second season of
stranger things the demidogs are the
second to last development stage of the
demogorgon while they're significantly
smaller and weaker than the adult
creature they're still highly dangerous
and can do a lot of damage as poor bob
newby and a whole bunch of lab workers
found out during the second season of
stranger things unless it somehow turns
out to be dustin's semi-friendly former
pet dart the presence of a demidog in
the prison is highly concerning after
all it means that the adult demogorgon
isn't the only one in the complex will
this be the sole demma dog in there or
will hopper joyce and the others have to
deal with an entire pack
the back half of the trailer really
ramps up the action and includes a
surprising moment in which lucas throws
a solid punch at his teammate jason in
an attic drenched in blue light
it's not surprising that these two have
finally come to blows since lucas
disagrees with the way jason and the
rest of the jocks are hunting eddie and
the rest of the hellfire club in volume
1. although lucas tries to expand his
social circle in season 4 it's great to
see him stay loyal to his true friends
hopefully lucas beating jason is the
bully's comeuppance for his arrogant
behavior
it looks like the fight takes place in
the attic of the creel house an
important place the gang has already
visited to look for clues about victor
creel and vecna clearly this is going to
be a key location in the final battle
because the trailer also shows 11
screaming in the upside downs version of
the house
okay it's time to talk about nancy
wheeler and steve harrington it's very
clear in volume one that nancy isn't
sure whether she wants to continue her
relationship with jonathan because of
the huge distance between them now that
he's living in california with joyce
will and eleven but while she's mulling
all this over she starts getting closer
with steve again
interesting the new trailer shows off a
couple of moments with nancy and steve
making their way through the upside down
and it's clear they're trying to keep
each other safe
it's entirely possible that they'll get
together in volume two and honestly
we're kind of rooting for it at this
point with one key reservation although
they do make an adorable couple their
love connection definitely spells danger
for the duo stranger things never lets
us off with an uncomplicated happily
ever after robin delivers a particularly
foreboding line at the end of the
trailer when she says she has a terrible
feeling that it might not work out for
us this time uh oh surely that paints a
target on steve's back thankfully there
isn't long to wait stranger things 4
volume 2 arrives on netflix on july 1
2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]